bonjour à tous merci de nous retrouver
sur public sénat à suivre cet après-midi
sur notre antenne l audition de jean
yves grall c'est le directeur général de
la santé il est entendu par la mission
commune d'information du sénat sur les
implants et les prothèses à visée
médicale mais aussi esthétique c'est un
bernard cazeau sénateur socialiste de
dordogne est aussi rapporteur de cette
mission qui l'interrogent
cette audition intervient après la
publication la semaine dernière d'une
étude en grande bretagne qui est-il que
le taux de rupture des prothèses
mammaires pip et et bien s'élève entre
15,8 pour cent et 33,9 % au lieu des 2 à
5% estimés auparavant
je vous rappelle que d'après le dernier
bilan diffusé par les autorités
sanitaires en france mi mars
20% des femmes porteuses de prothèses
mammaires pays paie et bien s'était fait
retirer à ses prothèses tout de suite
donc direction la salle médicis à
poursuivre cette audition bon après midi
à tous mes chers mes chers collègues
donc après une semaine d'interruption
notre mission d'information reprend ses
travaux et nous accueillons aujourd'hui
donc monsieur jean yves grall qui est
directeur général de la santé qui est
accompagné de madame catherine chaume
chaumât sous directrice de la politique
des pratiques et des produits de santé
ainsi que monsieur jean liedtke richon
qui est adjoint au chef du bureau
environnement extérieur et produits
chimiques à la dgs donc comme vous le
savez la dgs est compétente en matière
de santé publique et d'urgence sanitaire
mais vous êtes surtout au coeur de toute
l'organisation administrative est donc
au coeur de notre de notre sujet
s'agissant tout d'abord des dispositifs
médicaux implantables
donc nous souhaiterions vous puissiez
nous apporter des précisions sur les
enseignements et les suites que l'on
peut tirer du scandale pays tp ip mais
aussi de la sphère des prothèses de
hanche depuis qui depuis malheureusement
a défrayé la chronique et bien que bien
évidemment notre mission n'a pas du tout
vocation
à s'immiscer dans quelques procès que ce
soit c'est intéressant pour nous de voir
quelles propositions de modification de
la législation nous pourrions faire à
l'issue de ces à l'issue de ces de ses
affaires nous devons aussi comme vous le
savez raisonner en termes de sécurité
sanitaire en matière d'intervention à
visée esthétique qui est un sujet qui
est le deuxième gros sujets j'allais
dire de notre de notre mission dans un
contexte bien évidemment très différent
puisque ce sont les interventions qui
sont pratiqués à priori sur des
personnes en bonne santé et n'est donc
que nous attendons de votre part des
précisions sur l'exercice de la médecine
esthétique notamment en matière de
formation mais aussi sur les différents
types d'actes qui se pratiquent de
manière de plus en plus courante dans
une logique parfois plus commerciale
dans des commerces spécialisés comme le
blanchiment de dents et là
l'interdiction de certaines pratiques se
pose et j'espère que vous pourrez nous
en dire plus à ce sujet donc je me dois
vous dire que cette audition est ouverte
à la presse et au public qu'elle fait
également l'objet d'un enregistrement
audiovisuel et qu'elle est retransmise
en direct sur le site du sénat donc je
me dois de vous demander votre accord
sur cette retransmission et je laisse la
parole à notre rapporteur monsieur
cazaux qui après un propos introductif à
une série de questions à vous poser très
bien merci
même la présidente des dames messieurs
moi je vais vous poser trois séries de
questions
vous avez certainement connaissance une
première série ce tuto sur la
réglementation et sur son usage
une deuxième série sur le développement
de la médecine esthétique et une
troisième sur les angles encadrement
ceux de ses actes à visée esthétique tel
qu'un peu les évoquer même la présidente
dans son préliminaires non sur le
premier groupe de questions bon
l'actualité récente a été marquée par la
répétition d'incidents relatifs à la
sécurité dispositifs médicaux
implantables
pourquoi le dispositif de sécurité sans
intérêt de matériovigilance n'at-il pas
été en mesure d'identifier plus tôt les
déficiences des prothèses pays p et si
on sort du cap et ip
c'est une des raisons de cette mission
qui elle relève plutôt de la fraude il
faut bien le dire
pourquoi l' alerte est elle d'abord
donné ailleurs qu'en france on prend
l'exemple de l'australie dans la sphère
des prothèses de lens est depuis quelle
mesures ont été prises par la djs alors
là c'est directement pour vous tutelle
de l'afssaps pour prévenir la récurrence
de tels événements ou en tout cas pour
permettre une détection plus rapide déjà
levé matière
la présidente monsieur le rapporteur m
messieurs je vais répondre à votre votre
série de questions de la façon la plus
concise possible et à cette première à
cette première interrogation souligné
l'importance de la déclaration et des du
signal de la déclaration des effets
indésirables du signal de
matériovigilance significatif je pensais
et les chiffres l'ont montré que la
détection à travers la lessive de
matériovigilance n'a pas été optimale
dans la mesure où il n'y a pas eu il ya
eu très peu de déclarations jusqu'en
mars 2010 date à laquelle à la suite de
l'inspection réalisée par l'afssaps sur
site et la découverte de la fraude elle
même ils y avaient jusque là
relativement peu de déclarations et
pas de signe au niveau de l'afssaps
laissant apparaître qu'il y avait une
importance quantitative de problèmes
supplémentaires avec les prothèses pip
et je pense que tout ce sujet de la
déclaration des effets indésirables du
système de vigilance et est un des
éléments clés de la sécurité sanitaire
de la surveillance du dispositif
ce dispositif fait à travers quelques
chiffres par exemple nous avions de
l'ordre de 40 40 déclaration d'effets
indésirables je crois en début en 2009
sur les prothèses pip est pour vous
donner un exemple les déclarations
étaient 10 11 fois plus importante entre
mars 2010 et décembre 2011 qu'elle
n'avait été entre 2001 et 2010
et pour avoir un ordre d'idée nous avons
eu récemment les dernières données du
recueil régulier de l'afssaps en matière
de déclaration et nous avons eu ne
serait-ce qu'au mois de mars 2012 près
de 200 déclarations de rupture survenue
en mars 2012
c'est à dire des ruptures cliniques ou
des ruptures de prothèses pip est
retrouvé à la suite d'échographie donc
actuellement depuis il a mis sur le sur
la lumière de ce drame
nous avons des déclarations régulières
et très importantes de matériaux vision
ce qui se font alors qu'elle se faisait
sûrement mois avant donc à la réponse c
il n'y a pas eu de signalement ou de
signal
c'est pas la déclaration qui a fait la
rupture des prothèses non bon c'est pas
brutalement
on vous a vu des ces informations parce
qu il ya eu ce problème des prothèses
mais certainement qu'il ya eu pas mal de
rupture précédemment passé pas venu
comme ça tout donne absolument puisque
ce que je vous demande c'est pour
quelles raisons comment vous verriez
vous le problème de
la connaissance justement et de la
vérification
parce que s'il n'y a pas de vérification
bon c'est une affaire entre le
chirurgien et s'impatientent
et puis c'est terminé le vous le
le niveau 2 d'incidents retrouver dans
le cadre de la matériovigilance je viens
de le dire est un élément important
deuxième élément c'est des conditions
mêmes de l'organisation de la
surveillance une fois sur le marché de
ces prothèses qui pose problème c'est à
dire que nous avions d'une part des
organismes notifiés qui faisait des
contrôles réguliers dans le cadre jeudi
d'une fraude donc avec des masques âge
etc
vous connaissez le sujet et d inspection
de l'autorité réglementaire qui lave sap
qui se sont pas déroulées qui en a pas
eu
mais il n'y avait pas de signalement non
plus à l'afssaps ni de matériovigilance
ni de la part de l'organisme notifié le
crois que c'est comme ça qu'on peut
expliquer que les choses ont été dites
vous qu'est ce que vous en pensez vous
ben je pense que le système n'est pas et
l'a prouvé sur les dispositifs médicaux
optimale et qu'il est nécessaire le
moins qu'on puisse dire
il est nécessaire d'apporter des
modifications qu'on propose d'ailleurs
dans ce sens là alors ces propositions
d'amélioration elles viennent d'une part
nous sommes en train de travailler sur
la réorganisation du système des
vigilances nous avons remarqué que
l'importance c'était que lier la
possibilité de déclarer de déclarer
facilement que ce soit clair que ce soit
lisible et qui n'est pas de frein entre
le déclarant et l'organisme chargé de
traiter la déclaration donc c'est un
voudrait mettre en place un portail
unique des déclarations de vigilance
dans le pays de rendre la déclaration
est aisé face illisible et surtout qu'
un retour de la déclaration faite par le
déclarant et troisièmement de mettre
aussi dans la boucle une articulation
systématique avec le niveau régional ça
c'est pour les déclarations sur
l'évolution même du système tel que
vient de parler des organismes notifiés
d'une part et d'autre part des
inspections
c'est 2
d'imposer tout d'abord dans
l'information aux fabricants de
communiquer à l'afssaps toute
interdiction restrictions imposées dans
d'autres pays par l'autorité compétente
de ce pays
d'autre part d'asseoir une un meilleur
contrôle des organismes notifiés et de
leurs j'adhère de leur reconnaissance en
tant que tel au niveau européen
et puis de sérier les dispositifs ça
existe déjà et que les dispositifs
particulièrement sensible de niveau 3
soit soumis à une inspection régulière
au moins annuels par part l'afssaps
tout ceci nécessite à mon avis et c'est
le cas une une une coopération et
surtout des demandes de modification de
la législation européenne
laissant apparaître on le verra sûrement
plus tard la nécessité aussi de mettre
en place un dispositif c'est notre avis
un peu analogue à celui qui existe pour
les médicaments et notamment non
seulement des études de pré post
exposition mais peut-être aussi des
études préalables à une à ce qui
ressemblerait une autorisation de mise
sur le marché
dans le marché des médicaments parce
qu'une sévère 7
c'est ce qu'on propose c'est un thème
que nous ne sommes pas certains que les
simples études pré et post exposition
qui sont qui sont proposés ou qui sont
qui seraient proposées dans ce cadre
suffisent il nous semble que en tous les
cas pour les dispositifs médicaux dont
le don là comment dire la nature est
très hétérogène avec plusieurs classes
on a vraiment des choses tellement
d'importance diverse au moins que les
dispositifs implantables dispositif de
classe iii soit soumis à minima à des
contrôles prêt prêt mis sur le marché et
comment travaillez-vous alors avec
l'afssaps et la haute autorité de santé
pourra suivre assurer ce suivi des
dispositifs médicaux après la
commercialisation parce que vous avez
encore aujourd'hui un article
ça vaut ce que ça vaut puis c'est un
article de journal mai
à vérifier mais mais qui est très très
dur sur la pratique des firmes de
notification alors je crois
qu'effectivement il ya 2 2 il ya une
agence sanitaire d'une part et une haute
autorité indépendante de l'autre parent
qui interviennent dans le dispositif
c'est l'afssaps la prochaine à nsn qui
est chargée de la surveillance du marché
avec les contrôler
un certain nombre de dispositifs et
d'autre part la hs et quand elle chargée
de l'évaluation technique des
dispositifs médicaux par la cnedimts ce
avant la mise en remboursement éventuel
du sujet alors pour ce qui nous concerne
nous sommes l'autorité qui a la tutelle
et le pilotage de l'afssaps futur nsm et
nous sommes en train de mettre en place
les dispositifs dans le contrat
d'objectifs et de performance qui va
nous lié de façon assurée réellement ce
pilotage sur l'émission et sur le
contrôle
quant à la haute autorité de santé nous
essayons de mettre en place un
dispositif qui tiennent compte de son
caractère indépendant d'une part n'a pas
de tutelle en tant que tel et mais il ya
une demande aussi de la de la chaise que
nous puissions travailler plus par une
convention à défaut d'un contrat
d'objectifs et de performance de façon à
pouvoir avoir un lien et soumettre un
certain nombre de demandes parfois
rapides à lâchait son l'a vu d'ailleurs
sur la médecine esthétique bien ce n'est
pas quelque chose de plus précis que les
dispositifs de contrôle envisagé
c'est très vague nous dit mais je vous
dis que la halle à l'afssaps
et enfin on est en train de mettre en
place des dispositifs d'accord lesquels
on est en train de travailler sur le
contrat d'objectifs et de performance
qui va lier l'état donc la direction
générale de la santé et son opérateur
qui est l'abstract de façon à soir dans
le contrat qui va nous lier les
modalités que nous souhaitons voir
mettre en oeuvre quand aux contrôles et
aux inspections sur les dispositifs
médicaux on est en train de le mettre en
oeuvre à leur grand talent de mettre en
oeuvre
qui appâtent il n'y a pas d'autres
d'autres missions particulières non je
n'ai pas de précisions vous apporter la
trêve actuelle
voilà et c'est pour quand lors la
création de l'année ce n est sur le
point de se faire et nous nous donnons
trois quatre mois pour réaliser ce
contrat d'objectifs est parfaitement ce
qui a vocation à soit réellement le
pilotage stratégique de la part de
l'état sur son opérateur en mettant en
évidence dans ce contrat ce que nous
souhaitons voir mettre en oeuvre c'est à
dire l'inspection régulière le contrôle
et un certain nombre de dispositions qui
permettront de s'assurer comme c'est de
bonne de bons usages entre l'autorité et
son opérateur bain de la sécurité
sanitaire nécessaire alors pour mon père
ce moment pour surmonter l'incident du
marquage ce et eux pour assurer une
bonne qualité de tous les dispositifs
médicaux implantables l'instauration
d'une obligation de réaliser des essais
cliniques
il serait pré ou post inscriptions
sommes talent une mesure qui permettrait
de remédier aux insuffisances actuelles
et
sont-elles réalisable je pense que il
est en tous les cas nécessaire de mettre
en place des dispositifs qui s'assure
d'un bénéfice risque de l'ensemble de
ces dispositifs je parlerai des
dispositifs auris niveau 3
essentiellement et comme je vous le
disais précédemment il est sûrement par
le niveau est nommé et comme je vous le
disais précédemment il me semble que ces
études cliniques pré et post
inscriptions sont certes intéressantes
apporte certainement un plus mais à
notre à notre sens ne sont pas forcément
suffisante et là encore je pense qu'il
vaut mieux nous soyons nous sommes
plutôt dans l'idée au delà de ses études
et ses essais cliniques qui n'en qu'on
aille vers une organisation analogue à
ce qui existe pour le médicament avec
une des dispositions d'autorisation de
mise sur le marché c'est en ce sens que
nous avons saisi la communauté
européenne pour vous aller de plus en
plus vers ramin ramasser les deux
médicaments et dispositifs bas sur
nohain sur le fonctionnement oui sur le
fonctionnement 8 c'est ce qu'on
souhaiterait mettre la surveillance sur
l'établissement des conditions laissant
apparaître qu'on peut mettre sur le
marché
un médicament d'un côté c'est pas
l'objet mais les dispositions aussi
parce qu'à l'heure actuelle ce n'est pas
ce n'est pas le cas ce sont des
établissements qu'ils ont pris forme à
ce tic qui peuvent mettre sur le marché
et avoir un marquage chez eux par des
organismes notifiés du mans qu'il est
européen et après le pour tous les
classes 3 ou juste sur une liste
positive c'est plutôt tout les classes
trois très bien seriez vous favorable à
la mise en place de registre puisque
vous savez que dans certains pays
grâce à ce système là on a été plus
rapidement informé des problèmes qui
créeront pu se faire ce apparaître oui
je suis pour ma part persuadé que les
registres sont des outils très important
très utiles pour suivre l'évolution dans
la vraie vie
deux de ces dispositifs implantés je
mettrai juste une attention particulière
sur sur les registres les registres
ce n'est pas tant leur intérêt me
semble-t-il que leur exhaustivité qui
permettent de tirer réellement partie de
leur existence qui est importante et
tout le sujet est de voir comment
pouvons nous rendre totalement exhaustif
les registres sur différents dispositifs
alors ça se passe en lien avec des
sociétés savantes bien évidemment il y
en a qui existent sont à un registre par
exemple sur des prothèses de hanche qui
existent de la voir les moyens d'avoir
des régimes qui soit vraiment performant
oui complet oui c'est ça ils ont ils ont
très peu de très peu de déclarations
finalement fait de déclaration
d'inscription dans le registre et c'est
en cette avancée dans l'action avant
l'heure la nécessité de déclaration à ce
niveau là je crois que vous devez
la question est de savoir comment
pouvons nous rendre nécessaire voire
obligatoire l'inscription dans un
registre sur un certain nombre de
dispositifs
alors il ya peut-être une idée qui
consisterait peut-être rallier la
procédure de remboursement à
l'inscription sur sur un registre
bon c'est une idée qui est à creuser
mais qui n'est pas qui n'est pas arrêté
mais je crois que la condition
importante c'est de voir les conditions
qui permettent l'exhaustivité en amont
c'est patent de registre en lui-même et
son exploitation que d'être certain que
l'ensemble des disques des informations
ils soient donc c'est une c'est un
sûrement à un point que j'ai rencontré
récemment la sofcot justement cet effet
là pour essayer de voir comment est ce
qu'on pouvait et j'avoue qu'on est en
train de travailler que nous n'avons pas
encore la réponse
entre la nécessaire exhaustivité et
surtout est en train de travailler sur
toute la réglementation
oui préalablement c'était quelque chose
dont j'ai été pas qu'ils semblent et il
n'était pas là réalise hors temps ou du
moins mon tout à fait nécessaire la
révision de la directive européenne sur
les dispositifs médicaux a commencé il y
a plusieurs mois bien avant la sphère
entre guillemets des prothèses pip
mais c'est un processus long de nature
européen et il y avait déjà bien
antérieurement
l'un travaille sur la sur la révision de
cette directive dans un sens sûrement
qui a été un peu raffermi pour accélérer
par les événements récents blé c'était
quelque chose qui était déjà en cours
je ne faudrait il pas également élargir
l'accès aux bases de données existantes
comme d'ahmed oui oui bien sûr bien sûr
bien sûr bien sûr je crois que toute la
transparence et tous la possibilité
d'avoir accès aux bases de données et de
nature être un élément d'information de
transparence et donc derrière de
d'alerté voire de sécurité donc bien sûr
d'ahmed est un une base de données la
communauté qui a qui devraient en
location et plus largement utilisé bien
sûr par un accès plus facilement que la
sous déclaration des incidents m'ont
parlé dans l'ensemble tout seul 1 et 2
mais de même que l'interprétation d'aidé
création d'événements déraisonnable
grave on va passer en développant de la
médecine esthétique
avez vous des éléments chiffrés
quant au nombre de médecins pratiquant
la médecine esthétique et chiffrés pour
les actes et les plus pratiqués nous
n'avons pas d'éléments chiffrés à vous
fournir ni au niveau de la dgsn l'heure
actuelle je crois que cela tient au fait
justement et on y viendra sûrement après
aux besoins de cadrage de la deux
de l'enseignement et
de l'individualisation de la discipline
en tant que tel à l'heure actuelle ces
actes de médecine esthétique sont
pratiqués par plusieurs spécialités par
plusieurs par plusieurs spécialités et
il est bien difficile d'avoir un
chiffrage cet effet là dans la mesure où
la discipline de médecine esthétique en
tant que tel n'existe pas stricto sensu
et à votre avis ses médecins
ils sont bien informés de ce qu'ils ont
des formations suffisante ce que ou est
ce que chacun fait un petit peu sa
petite tambouille et quelles sont les
pistes éventuellement si vous estimez
que c'est pas suffisant que vous
envisageriez pour l'améliorer je crois
que tout le monde voit bien la nécessité
absolue d'encadrer ces deux heures
prévues par la loi d'encadrer la
pratique de la médecine esthétique de ma
part je pense qu'il faut une formation
adaptée spécifiques
je ne suis pas certain que la formation
de diplômes d'université soit mon sens
suffisante la halle des médecins wii
uniquement
oui oui oui que la formation pour les
médecins de diplôme universitaire en
soit enfin d où d u soit suffisante je
suis plutôt partisan d'une formation
spécifique reconnu nationalement je ne
suis plus tout penche plutôt pour un
diplôme d'études spécialisées
complémentaires un desk sur le quai d'un
bateau l'ogre diront qu'ils sont
spécialisés pour pas mal d'entre eux et
qu'ils n'ont pas
à revenir sur wii ça sonne into
l'hétérogénéité
des disciplines mais vu la profusion
l'hétérogénéité là comme le dit et le
nombre de pratiquants et de pratiques
qui n'ont pas forcément tous deux
formations adaptées je pense qu'il
convient dans ce cadre là et vu
l'importance du sujet je suis partisan
pour ma part vous me demander d'être sur
un goût des esc qui n'exclut pas
d'ailleurs le fait que d'autres
spécialités puissent y accéder est et
ouest et desk
mon avis est un gage de qualité et
réservation je pense que c'est par une
formation spécifique de de haut niveau
homogène au niveau du pays que on peut
on peut on peut arriver à ça du moins c
c'est notre scène c'est mon avis sur sur
le sujet et je pense que c'est une
formation qui ne va pas non plus axée
uniquement sur les gestes mais une
formation générale sur aussi les effets
j'ai les effets dans le temps et la
prise en charge des complications
d'automation complète multi donc on va
complexifier les choses au parlant des
chirurgiens dentistes qui ne sont pas
trop ce médecin
donc on va vous demander
ou ce qu'il ya une controverse récemment
un sur eux on les a vus d'ailleurs les
chirurgiens dentistes
je peux vous dire que ils y tiennent pas
la peine de parce que non seulement
c'est à l'intérieur mais tout ce qui
touche à l'extérieur à l'origine où on
va bon donc j'aimerais bien que vous
nous disiez qu'est ce qui a poussé la
dgs et la djs à écrire une lettre
conjointe à l'ordre des chirurgiens
dentistes au sujet de leurs pratiques
d'utilisation d'acide hyaluronique
abbas et la saisine tout simplement
c'est la saisine qui nous a été faite
par l'ordre des médecins et des
chirurgiens dentistes qui nous a amené à
rappeler les termes du code de la santé
publique tout simplement dans la dans la
lettre qui dit que la pratique de l'art
dentaire comporte la prévention le
diagnostic et le traitement des maladies
congénitales ou acquises réelle ou
supposée de la bouche des dents des
maxillaires des tissus à tenant donc
nous avons répondu de façon factuelle en
inscrivant dans notre réponse à cette
saisine
le rappelle tout simplement du colosse
des médecins je comprends mais l'heure
des chirurgiens dentistes aussi ce sont
vous a demandé de faire hui les deux
points nous l'affirmé on vous le
confirme
d'accord mais vous êtes sûr c'est parce
qu'on a entendu la l'ordre des médecins
nous a sollicités se comprend mais
l'ordre des chirurgiens-dentistes je
vous confirme pas très les jeunes on va
vous en voulez cris quand même que ce
soit précis qu'on n'entende pas de
discours dont vous menez des actions
visant à mieux informer les patients
ainsi concerne la qualité mais également
les risques associés à certaines
procédures chirurgicales ou médicales
avisé citic donc je vous pose la
question
est-ce que vous visez mener ces actions
là elles sont déjà en cours plus qu'une
information est disponible sur le site
du ministère chargé de la santé sur les
risques de l'isad est possible à tout
âge et esthétique
oui sur les actes à visée esthétique sur
les actes à visée esthétique je vous
réponds que déjà il y a sur ce qui
concerne la lipolyse les activités
existent déjà et on va contribuer à
lubango voilà alors que vous inspire le
développement du tourisme en matière de
médecine et de chirurgie esthétique et
seul phénomène qui pèse ensuite sur le
système de soins français
c'est un phénomène qui est susceptible
de peser sur le système de soins
français avec les complications qui
peuvent survenir une fois le retour
sur le sol métropolitain et d'où
l'importance à mon sens que les
personnes qui vont recourir à ce type
d'actes quels qu'ils soient à l'étranger
s'informent bien sûr la qualité sûrs
la nature des actes et la nature de
l'environnement qui permettent d'éviter
les complications
c'est un phénomène qu'on voit fleurir
effectivement de plus en plus j'appelle
quand même à une certaine vigilance
quant aux critères de qualité dans les
pays où dans l'est dans l'est dans les
établissements ça se réalise en dehors
puisque se repose derrière le problème
de ces complications dont je n'ai pas à
l'heure actuelle d' état des lieux sur
le chiffrage de ce qu'on peut voir
arriver dans nos établissements ou
auprès des praticiens domaine vous savez
comment ça se passe c'est une officine
de tourisme quelconque qui proposent par
exemple en tunisie ou ailleurs
un séjour confédéral séjour complet dans
ce pays et ses jours qui comprend un
séjour res traitement rapide en milieu
chirurgicale suivie de soins en milieu
hôtelier
donc est ce que vous les gens vous
pouvez dire ce que vous voudrez
incertain
ce que ce que ma question allait plutôt
dans le sens est ce que vous êtes
capable de réglementer c'est officines
de tourisme qui propose cela parce qu
elle le propose en france
je crois que le d'abord sa touche
essentiellement la chirurgie venir mais
c'est pire parce que j aurai 24 heures
d'hospitalisation et on fait les soins à
l'hôtel ensuite c'est pas quand même
quelque chose de spécialement adapté à
ce type d'intervention sur le dispositif
du même nous n'avons pas d'action à
l'heure actuelle qu'ils soient mises en
oeuvre très honnêtement je pense que
c'est une réflexion qu'on doit mener
avec la direction générale de l'offre de
soins de juger d'abord de l'effectivité
je pense que là aussi on a besoin d'eux
de mesurer si tenté que c'est possible
les effets entre guillemets secondaire
de ses interventions à l'extérieur
savoir s'il ya beaucoup si ça repose sur
le système de soins en complications
derrière sûrement un travail je ne sais
pas si c'est très facile à un relevé et
derrière de effectivement de se poser la
question avec l'ensemble du ministère de
la possibilité ou la nécessité de
légiférer ou de mettre des red hot
questions proposées
oui non je n'ai pas de réponse formelle
ce sujet d'accord alors pour prendre les
dernières questions sur l'encadrement de
ces actes à visée esthétique
quel est le cousin spire le
développement et puis on va en voir tout
à l'heure à travers table ronde des
demandes d'actes à visée esthétique qui
sont pratiqués par des professionnels
non médecins et de chirurgiens dentistes
non médecins urgentistes souvent à
partir d'équipements ou de produits
d'origine mais kg pailhères reçu dans ma
boîte aux lettres et à trois jours une
publicité pour le laser nouveau laser et
on a évité allé le voir à toulon pensez
bien que ne pas aller à toulon gréaume à
éviter aller voir la démonstration à
toulon par exemple laser pulsé
je serai bien savoir ce que vous pensez
de cela j'estime que cette situation
telle que vous la décrivez n'est pas
satisfaisante du fait de l'absence de
textes réglementaires d'encadrement qui
puisse indiquer très clairement qui peut
faire quoi et comment
de plus ce vide réglementaire me
semble-t-il peut être utilisé en mettant
en avant l'élaboration par certains
professionnels de de normes avec l'aide
de l'afnor sur des actes à visée
esthétique à risque sérieux qui peuvent
développer favoriser développé d'une
activité esthétique sans limites
sécuritaires ce qui m'amène à dire qu'il
est important est important d'avoir
rapidement des dispositions
d'encadrement ce que nous sommes ce que
nous avons fait et ce qui est en cours
l'article un article du code l'est le
elle 11 51 2 permet au ministre de la
santé d'encadrer les actes à visée
esthétique qui présentent un risque
sérieux pour la santé des personnes
un décret précisera la qualification et
la formation des professionnels de santé
qui pourront pratiquer des actes à
risque sérieux et dans quelles
conditions
créé à venir un décret à venir
il faut absolument que les actes à
risque sérieux il n'est pas envisageable
qu'ils ne puissent pas être effectuée
par des professionnels compétents
nous avons trois décrets préparation
après un décret d'encadrement des actes
à visée esthétique réalisés par les
médecins qui sera suivi par un décret
pour les chirurgiens dentistes et un
décret pour la profession des
esthéticiens le premier décret est prêt
il a été concerté
le premier décret porte sur des médecins
préfet sur les médecins ont été sur la
les exigences de prades et exigences en
terme de pratique d'actes de médecine
esthétique particulière risque sérieux
est prêt les deux autres sont en cours
dans le 2ème régressé sur les dentistes
sur les esthéticiennes et un troisième
sur les changes et un dentiste
on a même régressé sur les
esthéticiennes voilà et le troisième sur
les dentitions échange d'un dentiste sur
j'aime en piste et les premiers à venir
les décrets sont à venir le premier est
prêt a été largement concerter les deux
autres sont en cours d'établissement
oui mais le premier c'était le plus
facile à villé près quand bon point
prévoyez pas quelle dimension du temps
les autres à goutte est sorti ce projet
et
fini a été transmis à l'autorité
signataire et nous attendons la
publication pour ce qui nous concerne le
décret effet transmis donc je crois que
vous avez répondu à ma deuxième question
qui sur les procédures d'interdiction
ainsi que sur la troisième question il
ya une question que je voulais vous
poser
oui comment comptez-vous rebondir après
la nation partiel par conseil d'état du
décret du 11 avril 2011 relatif à
l'interdiction des techniques de lyse
adipocytaire oui ce décret donc a été
portée au conseil d'état
par des différentes associations
organisations professionnelles et a
finalement été entre autres guy mais
séparés en deux avec la reconnaissance
de l'interdiction pour les pratiques
chadi réfractive haut niveau lui pose
iter et la non-reconnaissance de
l'interdiction pour les pratiques
extérieur gd dire externe
donc nous avons sollicité à la fois la
haute autorité de santé et lançait ce de
façon à nous éclairer sur la
reformulation et l'établissement d'un
d'une disposition qui soit plus adapté
donc nous sommes actuellement en attente
de leur avis j'ai demandé aussi un avis
à la lâchait c'est un peu à part mais
c'est à ces concours quand même
concernant les risques liés à
l'utilisation des ultraviolets et des
produits de comblement et de la
mésothérapie alors on va vous parler des
bars à sourire marques déposées par ces
faux rend alors à périgueux deux bars à
sourire se sont ouvert cette semaine
comme je suis périgourdin joué 10 mais
ça veut dire qu'il n'a quand même pas
mal qui dans une petite ville il ya déjà
2 kg par semaine ça doit ça doit ben
alors
quelles mesures avez vous prises afin de
vous assurer qu'ils respectent la
réglementation notamment en matière de
concentration de produits utilisés quels
sont les produits d'ailleurs le donc le
peroxyde d'hydrogène donc le peroxyde
d'hydrogène
oui voilà
et cette alors nous conte nous
collaborons à l'élaboration d'une
directive du conseil d'une directive
européenne du 20 septembre 2011 qui
maintient la restriction de l'emploi du
peroxyde d'hydrogène les autres
comprimés d autres composés au mélange
libérant du peroxyde dans les produits
bucco dentaire cette directive récente
prévoit que les produits de blanchiment
contenant une concentration peroxyde
d'hydrogène comprise entre 0 1% et 6%
pourront être mises le main sur le
marché mais qu'ils pourront être vendus
uniquement à des chirurgiens dentistes
et cette directive européenne est en
cours de transposition des menteurs et
6% entre 0 1 6% dans exclusivement
vendus au procès en juin dentiste oui
tout simplement la base de la base
fondamentale de cette directive est que
la l'opération de blanchiment des dents
doit être précédé d'un examen dentaire
pour éviter des effractions et des
lésions importantes dedans en mauvais
état notamment sur l'émail avec des
douleurs importantes qui peuvent
survenir cet encadrement préalables à
l'utilisation de ce genre de produit
justifie bien sûr que les chirurgiens
dentistes soit au premier lieu
intéressés étant les seuls à pouvoir
faire bien évidemment un examen de la
dentition préalable quand les bars à
sourire que ce soit moins de 0 1%
ça ça n'empêche que
le produit en lui-même est un produit
qui nécessite comme je vous le disais de
par son agressivité d'avoir un bilan
dentaire donc la limite être 0,1
actuellement ces personnes sont en quête
si on s'en inquiète pour les raisons que
je viens de vous affirmer oui d'accord
la dgccrf a dit et nous mêmes avons déjà
fait un communiqué de presse laissant
apparaître dans ce cadre là
l'intérêt d'attention à porter c'est un
communiqué de presse du 5 décembre 2011
qui est à l'attention du public et qui
attire l'importance de la tension a
porté sur le traitement de blanchiment
des dents et par ailleurs nous avons
toute une campagne d'inspections nous
avons demandé que participant avec
l'afssaps et la dgccrf sur ces produits
se posent à notre problème d'ailleurs
qui sont les commanditaires l'exposition
à la lumière bleue des diodes qui n'est
pas sans problème quand il est mal
utilisée notamment sur le plan oculaire
c'était déjà démontré la directive est
en cours de transposition
elle est publiée la directive est en
cours de transposition dans notre droit
est vraiment pas banale
voilà donc à les publier sur leurs
erreurs et 6 oui c'est ça en cours de
transposition non ça c'est d'un autre
niveau
tu es un autre niveau la transposition
du droit européen donc nous y sommes
bons et dernière question les effets
néfastes de l'exposition croissante de
la peau rayonnements ultraviolets
artificiels l'élan a élevé ont été
récemment rappelé par des études
scientifiques envisagez vous de prendre
des mesures
trois types tout au moins de renforcer
l'information oui on veut pas je pense
que vous pouvez pas empêcher la vente de
lampes à uv mais bon il ya
avant de répondre sur les mesures à
prendre dans les mesures à prendre
se poser la question de l'accès à des
des machines enfin des des outils des
appareils à uv personnelles que l'on
peut trouver économies' soi même et qui
est un qui est sûrement à prendre en
considération à trois points
particuliers tout d'abord la rampe ou
renforcement de la réglementation en
général vis-à-vis de ces cabines à uv
ses terres quant à la formation des
professionnels
quant au contrôle des pratiques et quand
on contrôle des appareils même c'est un
cetain un renforcement réglementaire qui
a été mis en place depuis 1997 et qui
impose ses points la deuxième point
c'est la loi hpst a permis de dalou
redire la possibilité de sanctions aux
contrevenants j'allais dire que soient
administratives avec des possibilités de
fermeture ou bien des amendes des
pénalités financières et troisième axe
d'action c'est bien sûr l'information au
public sur les risques potentiels de
cette exposition aux uv et dans ce cadre
là une campagne de l'inpes a été réalisé
et sera poursuivie plus tard dans une
information permanente sur le sujet et
je crois que également l'attention
apportée je me répétais sur des
appareils individuels qui est un vrai
sujet très bien
très bien avant de passer la parole à
mes collègues pour savoir s'ils ont des
questions je vois j'ai 3 juste trois
questions très très simple pas toujours
les plus simples la première c'est sur
la question de la matériovigilance
l'obligation de déclaration pèse donc il
ya les la part producteurs et puis là
par utilisateur donc les les chirurgiens
essentiellement pour vous est ce que
cette obligation elle doit peser d'abord
sur les producteurs ou d'abord sur les
sur les utilisateurs
deuxième question concerne les actes à
visée esthétique puisque vous avez
expliqué que vous aviez des décrets pour
les encadrer est ce que la définition de
ce qu'on entend par actes à visée
esthétique dangereux est clair et ce qui
a besoin de la clarifier dans le cadre
de la dans le cadre de la loi
et puis la même question s'agissant des
responsabilités notamment pour la
médecine esthétique
est ce que la question de la
responsabilité est aussi clair
aujourd'hui en ce qui concerne la
médecine esthétique la responsabilité la
responsabilité si si il y a des
conséquences néfastes par exemple à
l'utilisation du v en cabine ou
blanchiment de dents dans un bar à
sourire est ce que le partage la preuve
de cette responsabilité de partage des
responsabilités est clair sur votre
première question
il me semble que l'obligation de
déclaration doit peser sur l'ensemble la
fois la catégorie des entre guillemets
les fournisseurs c'est ce que nous
voulons mettre aussi au niveau européen
comme je le disais deuxième point bien
sûr des professionnels et je crois qu'il
faut rappeler plus que jamais que le
signalement
en général des faits jugés indésirables
est très important et cette histoire de
là d'autres aspects que vous êtes unies
monsieur le rapporteur montre à quel
point c'est un des éléments de vigie de
notre système de sécurité sanitaire et
je ne reviendrai pas ce que je disais
mais je crois que c'est ce que nous
faisons travailler je suis pour la
rendre la plus efficiente et efficace
possible
sur l'ensemble dé vigilance puisque nous
avons un certain nombre
deuxième point sur l'encadrement des
actes la loi ne le prévoit pas mais le
décret le prévoir à sur une liste la
plus complète et la plus précise
possible des dispositions des actes à
visée esthétique en médecine esthétique
quant à la responsabilité je crois
qu'elle est clairement me semble-t-il à
travers le lait fekter même de l'acte
relativement clair me semble-t-il moi je
vais pas
le corps du sujet ouais bon à écouter
mes chers collègues x vous avez des
questions oui voir quelques précisions
par rapport aux propositions qui ont été
faites notamment en ce qui concerne
contre l'évaluation avec une piste qui
est là et même très bien qui a rejoint
un peu les réflexions qu'on s'était posé
une deuxième avec la formation notamment
des médecins par le biais d'un diplôme
spécifique de sc qui paraît
effectivement intéressante où j'ai pas
bien vu les pistes qui pouvait être
suivie c'est par rapport à nos pays
voisins de façon à voir si sur le plan
européen on peut avoir une des
propositions relativement homogène ou
uniformes de façon à ce que les transits
entre les différents pays soient bien
établies en ce qui concerne ces
différentes normes et puis après voir
dans le système d'évaluation qui peut
être une surveillance relativement
longue peut-être plus longue que les
médicaments voire ceux qui se font
implanté justement des dispositifs à
l'étranger dans des pays non-européens
notamment comment on peut évaluer
derrière le suivi de ces gens là et les
répercussions de façon à essayer de de
dénoncer les pratiques qui ne sont pas
soumises aux mêmes règles
alors quelles sont les pistes dans ce
domaine vous plaît ce que ce que vous
soulignez monsieur sur les sur les
dispositifs c'est ce que nous avons fait
remonter comme demande à la commune pour
la révision des directives européennes
c'est à dire qu'il y ait l'obligation
d'information d'un pays à l'autre par
les
les firmes entre guillemets qui qui ont
eu des interdictions connu des problèmes
d'une part et deuxièmement que lier un
dispositif qui soit mis en place et
justement par cette ce niveau me
semble-t-il europe est en tous les cas à
puis après les autres pays de de
coopération entre les états pour
l'information réciproque lorsqu'il y à
des signalements particulier qui se font
et je crois que c'est un des points que
nous avons souligné d'amélioration dans
le positif comme vous le soulignez
justement de dispositifs qui sont par
essence me sur l'ensemble des pays pas
seulement européen que l'on a vue qui
aurait cette coopération était renforcée
forte voire organiser aurait peut-être
permis d'avoir des éléments génère
cohérent et concordant
avant avance concerne les prothèses pip
est peut-être mais je pense que la
coopération ce que nous réclamons ce que
nous avons demandé à la commission
européenne en tous les cas que c'était
dispositif d'information réciproque soit
rendue obligatoire en cas de problème
oui bien sûr le tourisme à visée
esthétique est de plus en plus
développées envie de le dire et c'est
une réalité
en conséquence j'ai à dire les réactions
néfastes qui puisqu'ils puisqu'ils
peuvent exister
est ce qu'elles sont pris en charge
après par la sécurité sociale
est ce que les médecins kiki et découvre
j'allais dire ces patients qui viennent
les voir pour se faire soigner
est ce que les médecins ne peuvent pas
dénoncer directement je pense qu'ils
peuvent le faire mais la prise en charge
des actes quand est ce qu'elle se fait
est ce qu'on les prend en charge à 100%
est ce qu'on les proches en fonction
bien sûr du cac opératoire est ce que
c'est la sécurité sociale est ce que
c'est le oui qui paie qui prend en
charge ces dépenses qu'elles soient
hospitalière d'hospitalisation bien
alors de chirurgie est ce que c'est
normal
voilà c'est une question qui me pop ce
qui me pose problème sur sur la prise en
charge dès lors qu'il y à des
complications donc des pathologies qui
sont mises en évidence les complications
et les les personnes sont prises en
charge par la sécurité sociale aux
tarifs habituels me semble-t-il
par contre ce que vous soulignez madame
se rejoint un peu le leitmotiv de de ce
que j'ai pu le dire c'est l'importance
de la déclaration du signalement
qui doit passer plus dans l'est dans les
moeurs si j'ose m'exprimer ainsi
notamment de la part des professionnels
et bien sûr je pense que s'il ya des
complications des choses qui
apparaissent comme étant rédhibitoire
bas que les professionnels signalent la
effectivement oui et 12 que vous dites
c'est que la facilitation et laissait
d'organisation meilleur de clarté de
lisibilité de retour aussi des
professionnels quand il déclare sur leur
déclaration est importante et ce que
nous mettons en place la actuellement
c'est à la fois votre question est ce
qu'à d'autres questions non s'il ya que
les sénateurs qui sont autorisés à poser
des questions mais écoutez je vous je
vous remercie monsieur le rapporteur
si vous n'avez plus de plus de questions
je vous remercie
voilà c'est la fin de l'audition de jean
yves grall directeur général de la santé
pour revoir les travaux de la mission
d'information du sénat sur les implants
et les prothèses notre site internet
publicsenat.fr
à suivre l'émission politique de la
rédaction de public sénat preuve par 3
qui reçoit ce soir l'ancienne candidate
socialiste à la présidentielle de 2007
ségolène royal
bonne soirée à tous
oui